it's video games are the same way don't
never got into video games the only
thing that I you know have a clear issue
with is you know yeah but you know what
I don't I don't honest I'm gonna be
honest with you
may I be honest with you you're for how
many years have we known each other
honest with each other
yeah I don't if if I would to describe
you to somebody I don't think that that
would be in there yeah see and you know
let me tell you something about fat
people fat people listening right now or
heavyset people listening when I look
back at pictures of myself in yearbooks
okay
eighth grade ninth grade seventh grade
when I was in the eighth grade I was six
foot a hundred and sixty-five pounds but
I was the fat kid when I look back at
pictures of myself as a freshman I was
six foot one 220 pounds but I was the
fat kid when I look back at pictures of
myself in the fourth grade I was the
chubby fat kid but my point is as I grew
out of that but I was still the biggest
kid in my class so I've never not
thought of myself as the fat kid but
you're not the first person to say like
when I see you that's not what I think
do you know what I mean but my I've
never had any other opinion of myself so
people listening you know it's like they
say when you have a pimple on your face
you see it other people don't really
notice it but you you you really get it
like you have that thing on your nose
right now that's a huge huge thing what
is that is it a growth you should have
that looked at pimple face no but anyway
good lord I can't look at anything else
Daniel all right I'm trying to look in
your eye
but I look back at those pictures and I
get sad for myself because I think like
well I wasn't fat in seventh eighth
ninth grade and then but the you know
but don't you think that the reason why
you're where you're at is because of
those issues that you had growing up
because you use people use humor as a
defense mechanism right and you want to
become an actor to become somebody else
or you like pretending to be I mean I
feel like some of my self-esteem issues
and problems I had as a young person
bleeds into my career has something to
do with it like yeah some sort of cat
like up launching pad or no nest yeah I
what have you did you watch the Chris
Farley documentary that I was just on
it's phenomenal you need to watch it but
what it reminded me of I was in Chicago
and Chris died and I only saw him in
person once but I know his brother Kevin
I know his brother John and I know a lot
I know all those guys do I love that
knew them that knew Chris and a lot of
people that knew Chris so I felt like I
after his passing kind of got to know
him a little bit but that documentary
was great and one of the things that I
was telling Tyler that it really
solidified in my brain is that Chris
Farley kind of taught me what I wanted
my career to look like or help me define
it because I never wanted to be that
version of an actor of where I'm taking
my shirt off and dancing around didn't
mean I didn't love him for being able to
do it yeah and do that stuff but it
meant like wow I don't possess that and
I don't want to pretend I possess that
ability to do that right and what it
taught me was like I have insecurities
deep insecurities but you know what my
insecurities aren't as deep as that book
into drugs and to look into alcohol and
look into this like this notion of
getting up on stage and going berserk
yeah you know I mean I think that you
would do it in as a role yeah you could
play that guy but the saddest line we
were in that documentary is when he
calls a friend of his and on Saturday
night when he's on Saturday Night Live
and he's talking to her at Second City
and he says well they wrote a sketch
again this week making fun of the fat
guy
there's just something
he just it broke my heart like yeah yeah
I broke my heart because he was willing
to do it for not necessarily the best
healthy reasons yeah yes yeah like you
know I you know a girl might do every
dude in high school she's looking for
something right yeah yeah and I know I
did one line in David Spade's Hawaii
movie one line when movie it's Adam
Sandler produced I don't know but I knew
yeah he hasn't come out yet so what
Netflix okay but I was in Hawaii and I
was eating dinner with David and we
talked about um fart Chris Farley and he
told me that when he went Farley died
you know where he was and the way he was
describing number one you could tell
that Chris Farley that you and I like
everyone in this room we'd be his friend
yeah he's one of the nicest guys and
number two um how heartbreaking that
moment was for David you know you know I
mean I'm sure that's not saying anything
that you know he totally told me yeah
he's still peace I mean he's on the
record that he still can't talk about it
a tremendous and we can't so Fame you
could tell that it was emotionally like
still raw for him and and he even hangs
out with Chris I mean his brothers was
it whatever avaandjohn yeah and it's
still hard for him because it reminds
them of Chris but um yeah it's the what
a sad but what a talented guy man
unbelievable legend um Pat Finn is in
the documentary and he's a friend of
mine and he he said one of the things
that stuck with me is that Chris
surrounded himself with such amazing
funny people and the worst thing about
his funeral was all those amazing funny
people crying yeah yeah yeah but it's
also like you know we we have friends
that you know that are in that that have
been in that struggle before so it's
like people Chris was important to a lot
of people you know and they said why are
we going this guy's wedding why are we
going to his funeral
yeah he couldn't get out of it John
Goodman you got to watch it dude it's no
no I wanna watch what is it on what is
it on
a Bach biography channel I think Amy
yeah it's a queer gonna watch it tonight
yes
[Music]